ciao a tutti bentornate solito storie
oggi all'ultimo richiesta ma l'avete
chiesto in tantissimi di rifare la
challenge provando minare 6 reale o se è
disegnato o appunto trovato nuovi video
dell'artista hauer li fa era challenge
assieme come sempre anche voi dovrete
partecipare io dirò il numero numero uno
e voi scrivete nei commenti numero 1
sinistra reale oppure sinistra disegnato
del 3 reale e poi alla fine del video
vediamo quanti punti avete fatto voi e
se avete fatto più punti di me mi avete
battuto altrimenti ho vinto io siete
pronti prevede poco patatine e iniziamo
subito mi raccomando lasciate un bel
live se volete vedere altri challenge
segue sociale nei 10.000m farò un'altra
anche il numero uno il quale è reale e
quale è disegnato di queste due uova
fritte
io sono super reality che tutti e due
vivete voi nei commenti numero uno qual
è quella reale quella sinistra o quella
a destra
io dico che quella reale quella sinistra
perché ha più
più riflessi qua invece questo mi sembra
un po più opaco vediamo quindi non per
volere di costini tra scrivete la vostra
risposta nei commenti
[Musica]
la sensi in pieno
e non con lo trovo non ci posso credere
fatto benissimo
assurdo come è possibile
e bravissimo
si chiama mosley è veramente
veramente bravo di insegnare ok numero
due
qual è quella reale quella a sinistra o
quella a destra allora quali sembra di
vedere un po meglio almeno penso perché
poi alla fine sembra sempre il contrario
di quello che penso io
comunque secondo me numero 2 quella
reale e questa a sinistra scrivete voi
vi commenti numero 2 qual è quella reale
e quella sinistra quella destra
vediamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sì numero 3
qual è quello reale con la sinistra o
quello a destra condicio sembrano reali
tutte e due
se mi sembra che abbia i bordi un po
troppo marcati quindi forse stato
disdegnato numero 3 io dico che quello
reale quello a sinistra
scrivete voi che come numero 3 qual è
quello reale sinistra o destra
vediamo
[Musica]
numero 4 quale reale quale ha segnato
sinistra o destra allora qua mi sembra
di vederlo abbastanza chiaramente penso
a me sembra che in questo numero 4
quello reale sia questo a destra perché
mi sono posto abbiamo un primo messo
appunto siamo molto marcato nei bordi
netto qui io dico numero 4 quello reale
questo a destra scrivete voi nei
commenti il numero 4 qual è il reale
scritta o destra vediamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
tutto quindi sono tre punti nel 2 reti
scritto del trading 14 h fosse un numero
5 questo è un po particolare
secondo voi quale è reale questo a
sinistra cioè questi due o questo a
destra cioè tutto il pacchetto non si
sente che bisogna indovinare solo nelle
qui rizzi e queste qua dentro
quindi il numero 5 dico reale a destra
scrivete voi nei commenti numero 5 reale
sinistra o destra
vediamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
o no
[Musica]
semplifica tutto era reale e uno non era
reale di quelli a sinistra numero 6
questo livello genio bisogna indovinare
quale di questi è dipinto a mano quindi
sono tutti bene tranne uno questo è
difficilissimo allora proprio a queste
libere da qua questi mi sembrano tutti
felici passa è uno di questi
forse chi per capire va benvenuto e dico
questo qua è dipinto scrivete voi numero
6 centro sinistra a destra e basso
vediamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no non era quella di fare
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma quindi non era solo dipinto quindi
per quello era un po più difficile da
indovinare perché sembrava un
cioccolatino vero comunque numero 7
quale è reale e qual è disegnato di
questi due unicorni allora guardiamo
bene anche questo è fatto benissimo però
io penso che numero 7 quello reale sia
questo a destra scrivete voi che come il
numero 7 quale reale è finita o destra
non vendiamo
[Musica]
venite anche voi avete scritto numero 7
quella destra avete fatto un tutto ok
ragazzi numero 8 questo è un livello
molto difficile c'è scritto che una di
queste carte e reale
una di queste carte e gigante e una di
queste carte finta cerchiamo di
indovinare innanzitutto qual è il reale
allora reale
non lo so reale dico il treni picche
quella gigante quindi per la città che
dovrebbe fare più indietro rispetto alle
altre di collasso di cui è invece quella
finta di corsetti di quadri così a casa
scrivete la vostra risposta nei commenti
per la numero 8 vediamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
il 3 di picche era quello gigante
l'asso di cuori era quello finto e
l'aperta reale era il sette di quadri
ok numero 9 dobbiamo trovare quello
finto che penso che sia foto di di
vernice come l'altro cioccolatino allora
guardiamo bene la formate di oreo già mi
sembra che questo sia leggermente
diverso non lo sto mi sembra un po più
storto quindi numero 9 io mi butto e
dico che questo al centro scrivete voi
la vostra risposta nei commenti
vediamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sì questo è quello forse quello che
proprio buttata al caso o possono anche
non ha 4 punti mi sembra supera 10 qual
è il reale e quale è disegnato a
sinistra oa destra
questi dati abbastanza bene penso penso
che sia quello a sinistra sede che è
proprio diverso quindi 10 enrico quella
sinistra scrivete voi nei commenti 10
quello a destra quella sì sì era cosa
sinistra appunto quello disegnato di
cose prima prima forse sbagliato abbia
visto nel suo sonno reale cioè intendevo
psicolo designato non sto guardando
questo si vedeva appunto bene appunto
che la pelosi segnato o che il numero 11
queste difficoltà media bisogna
riconoscere quali di questi soldatini e
foto di vernice come quel primo appunto
bene perché mi bene sembrano tutti può
addirittura
non lo so io dico questo arancione a
destra voi scrivete nei commenti il
numero permessi qua il soldatino in
fatto di pernice secondo voi prendiamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
o quello
[Applauso]
[Musica]
c'è allora numero 12 bisogna trovare
quale di questi è finito dentro il frigo
questo modo più difficile anche perché
in continuo movimento
[Musica]
non solo secondo voi forse forse questa
bocca cola sì questa coca cola mi sembra
un po opache rispetto alle altre quindi
numero 12 e dico questa coca cola finite
voi nei commenti
vediamo non ci credo un altro punto 6
punti ha comunque era fatta molto molto
bene anche questa numero 13 questo mi
sembra difficilissimo lo stesso quale
reale qual è impegnato quella sinistra o
quello della quale è reale questo è
fatto davvero bene allora io dico che
quella reale e questo a destra scrivete
voi che commenti quale reale sinistra o
destra
mettiamo
[Musica]
no
un po meno significa creare incredibile
sosteniamo perfettamente che voi avete
scritto che quella reale da quella
sinistra avete preso un punto
ma
[Applauso]
[Musica]
vedere anche la storia si conclude qui
io ho fatto un totale di 6 punti se non
mi sbaglio
fatemi sapere nei commenti quanti punti
avete fatto voi se vi è piaciuto questa
chat e fatemi sapere se vorreste veder
le altre in cui indoviniamo assieme
oppure riti pure quali altri sono lenti
volete vedere del canale quelle che mi
interessano di chi non mi lascerò un
cuoricino e andrò a farle nei miei
prossimi video
ora vi lascio qua 4 quadrati su che
potete cliccare
se volete vedere leandre challenge se
volete fare qualche altro gioco come i
video divertenti cliccate su quella che
preferite tra questi quattro quadratini
e buona visione